I've blurted out the possibility that at
some point Sean Payton will be moving on
that that he'll leave before the Saints
ever asked him to leave and that maybe
at some point he'll inevitably be
coaching the Dallas Cowboys and that
that led us back to the comments from
last week from Jerry Jones Peter I think
we talked about this Wednesday of last
week when Chris Simms was on the show
Jerry Jones had been on Dallas radio one
oh five three the fan on Tuesday and he
was asked to make a commitment to Jason
Garrett and the host really didn't get
Jason Garrett's name all the way out
some of argued he was talking about
Scott Linehan but here's what Jerry
Jones said why would I put out some kind
of statement that says this is what
we're going to do when we might have an
opportunity here next week this is the
time when these things are thought about
this is the time when they're chewed on
this is when you may see an opportunity
next week that you didn't know existed
this week in the area of personnel or in
the area of coaching now as I said last
week unless they're going to clone Sean
McVeigh next week or reanimate Vince
Lombardi they already know what
opportunities are out there and the only
circumstances that would have changed
from last week to this week is the
availability of a coach who at the time
couldn't be approached couldn't be hired
couldn't be interviewed and now Sean
Payton's out there and they had to shake
up on Friday Scotland hands out they
haven't hired a new offensive
coordinator
I've Peter look I don't want to stir
things up unnecessarily and I think it
would be an upset if it happens but
would it shock anyone if Jerry Jones
rolls out of bed this morning tomorrow
Thursday Friday and says I'm moving on
from Jason Garrett we all would know
what he's going to try to do if he would
make that move now it would shock me but
it would not be it would not be totally
unexpected
it just wouldn't because you know Mike
two years ago when the Rams were in the
process of hiring Sean McVeigh the Rams
thought about making an offer for Sean
Payton didn't end up doing so but
considered it went through the
discussion stage of doing that
internally so there is the thought out
there that at least at that time that
was coming
of three seven and nines now but at
least at that time there was the thought
that maybe Sean Payton could be in play
and that is the reason the only reason
why I think it might happen but I
I doubt sincerely it'll happen but it's
just something that is deep in the back
of my mind
yeah and that connection seems to be
there and it's been there for so long
that you just feel like it's going to
happen at some point that Sean Payton at
some point will be the head coach of the
Dallas Cowboys and and it I guess in
theory it could happen this week more
PFC live ridiculous
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports